E aí galera que quase nunca não assiste
meu canal agora eu fico fingindo que não
faz 10 anos que eu não faço um vídeo
desse aqui mas é que eu estou na
Argentina ele treinando boxe boxer Novos
ares novos amigos né treinando aí um Um
negócio diferente né Depois que o King
me deu um [__] aí volte mesmo a gente
fica aqui sem fazer nada o que que eu
fiz eu fui assistir besouro Azul fui no
shopping à tarde fazer muito tempo que
eu ia no chão pra tarde Ninguém me
conhece ninguém tá nem aí para mim muito
bom faça um cardumezinho de criança digo
Oi meu Deus meu Deus do sequestro já sai
ninguém gosta de mim aqui eu acho muito
legal eu acho que eles até me odeiam
parecem assim aí beleza comprei minha
pipoca e tal eu entrei fui lá assistir
Se alguém quando eu já tinha comprado
foi que eu me liguei que era em espanhol
o filme de herói eu gosto de assistir
dublado por causa dos efeitos especiais
eu não consigo fazer os efeitos
especiais escutar em inglês e ler a
legenda para perceber o que tá
acontecendo a pessoa fala
de um negócio ali inflamável desodorante
sei lá o quê na legenda a pessoa tá
dizendo assim você não pode esquecer que
a explodiu eu consegui ler o resto que
eu olhei pra ver a explosão aí começa o
filme né Lógico tem que começar termina
né uma coisa que nem começou filme
começa eles procurando besouro E no caso
em espanhol é esse cara velho esse cara
veio aqui ó lá no Piauí a gente chama de
rola bosta se ele soubesse né eles tinha
procurado ou de inseto sei lá um cambito
né um Louva Deus Inclusive eu vou fazer
né esse filme do homem louva-a-deus vai
ter um enredo pesado né porque o
personagem que faz um louva-a-deus Ele é
teu então ele começa a sair na mídia
como super-herói hipócrita Hebert lixo
quando sair vocês vão ver aí beleza Eles
começam procurando besouro é escavando
com aquelas pentes aquelas coisinhas
assim e tal que elogia eles vão contando
a história da humanidade né escavando
direito e volta e meia né solta uma
maldição mas é coisa boa aí nós vemos a
primeira vez no nosso personagem
principal né ele tá chegando de viagem
como se estivesse voltando pra cidade
dele né no México com a família toda
mexicana eles vão comer taca como se
fosse um filme Meu E aí quando eu
chegasse na minha casa e fosse comer um
cuscuz é ele chega né liso nada do bolso
quando estão comendo já estão falando
que a família tá mal de grama ou fume
entrou tá todo mundo sempre mal de
grande pra falar a verdade o melhor
super-herói são homem-aranha se tu
tivesse devendo a casa até hoje tava
tirando foto lá tava lifans não sei E aí
eu comecei a perceber que eu tava
entendendo todo o filme Mesmo ele sendo
todo em espanhol eu parei para prestar
atenção que na dublagem dá para você
entender porque eles falam assim
tá fazendo o quê meu filho você entende
no meio da rua então ela é uma maneira e
eu Cadê a Bruna Marquezine porque quando
tem brasileiro do filme Eu quero que a
vinheta do filme começando esteja
aparecendo a pessoa já apareça assim ai
Brasil aí o nosso amigo personagem
principal arrume emprego junto com a
irmã dele no hotel de rico lá e quem é
que tá lá no hotel rodeado de segurança
avilando o fio na maior feitora com isso
que é um vilão de um filme o vilão do
filme é aquela pessoa que você discorda
como se você tivesse visto ela cometeu
uma infração de trânsito qualquer coisa
que a pessoa fala atualmente responde
automaticamente Cala a boca cara tu tá
errada Beleza ela está lá nesse hotel
que eles arrumaram emprego ele já é
muito esperto tenta entrar em contato
com a mulher né falar alguma coisa lá
bom dia e ela nem tchum nem como assim
se é outro ser humano que está do lado
dela não parecia eu chegando em alguma
mulher em alguma festa fora do Brasil
que vocês sempre falaram para mim me
aterrorizaram assim nos comentários Às
vezes pega uma mulher bonita porque tu é
rico e tu é famoso Cara eu estou aqui
para dizer para você que é verdade
quando eu tô fora do Brasil eu chego
numa mulher eu digo lá a mulher responde
oi é duas Coca Zero com gelo e limão
para mim por favor obrigado tá isso fora
do Brasil sei lá inglês em espanhol Cadê
que eu sei falar inglês e espanhol para
poder responder pra pessoa que eu não
trabalho ali naquele estabelecimento aí
eu pego as coca e entregue para ela
porque ela tá ali né eu fiz se eu quiser
ficar com alguém na Bélgica eu tenho que
ficar igual o Chaves comprando churros
dele mesmo Olá tudo bem Que tal a gente
dar uns beijos ah claro mas primeiro
você tem que me cortejar A Nossa você é
tão bonita que se você fosse uma carroça
Eu chupava até o pau do jumento você é
divertido vamos fumar um ali perto
daquele caminhão falei cara vem vem me
consolo né ele não sabe quem eu sou
história não conhece Bruna Marquezine
aparece a gente fica nervoso não sei
porque não tem nada a ver eu não tenho
nada a ver com isso não sou amigo dela
eu conheço ela a viela uma vez ou outra
assim Oi Bruna tudo bem e aí como você
tá a nossa Parabéns esse é aquilo muito
legal só isso mesmo mas aí vai aparece
ali naquela tela do cinema ali de
Hollywood mesmo você pensa meu Deus eu
sou brasileiro também minha amiga
nós dois aí carrinho lindo beleza aí a
Bruna né que a James o nome da
personagem dela é Jenny ela vai falar
com a vilão malfeitora sobre um projeto
de um super soldado que tinha sido
interrompido e a Jenny percebeu que ele
voltou a ser feito eles continuaram o
projeto e o menino por ali o principal
liso né sem dinheiro a Bruna Marquezine
tá brigando porque esse negócio do Super
soldado é tipo fabricar uma arma e ela
não gosta de negócio de arma a gente
descobre aí que ela é a filha do dono da
empresa que faleceu pelo que pelo que eu
vi no filme Ela é a filha do rico ela
não gosta de arma ela é a filha do rico
legal que tem os filhos de rico pau no
cu né que é aquele que fica conversando
perto de você a sua cabeça fica dizendo
assim você é irmão meu um menino desse
mas eu ia dar tanto tempo e até o fim do
rico legal que é aquele que fala um
negócio legal você até pensa assim oh
rapaz ele pensa não espera eu falo do
filho de rico ódio né sou hipócrita né
que pode meu Deus eu me tornei o que eu
mais odiava Rico
beleza elas estão discutindo né a Jenny
com a vilão malfeitora ó o menino vê a
discussão ele vai lá interrompe ei
pessoal é demitido
fumo aí ele toca com ela na saída depois
ela explica não pô porque você me ajudou
não precisa de ajuda de homem para falar
espanhol tudo dublado né que dá para
entender
nenhum meleca ai ela se sente meio assim
e fala assim me dá teu Zap aí ele passa
né papai ela fala não vai arrumar um
emprego para você ajeitar para você já
que você foi demitido aí por causa dessa
situação eu vou falar com você que se
aparece lá e eu arrumo um drop pessoal
de empresa fala Job né eles não passa
coordenadas eles passam braken o cinema
estava meio quente assim há várias
quebrado os ar condicionado do seio O
povo reclamando esse abando morrendo de
calor e eu né piauiense gente normal
vamos chorar mesmo ai no outro dia o
menino vai pra empresa Cruel demais a
empresa assim um negócio muito high-tech
sabe você vê que o negócio é avançado
pra ela e ele vai lá ver a Jenny quando
ele chega lá ela já tá fuçando as coisas
procurando o negócio dos Besouro o que é
que acontece ela são besouro azul aí tem
uma hambúrguer perto ela pega um
hambúrguer bota o Besouro na caixa do
hambúrguer em espanhol hamburguer muito
bom muito chato meu uma burguesa Eu
Jorge que gostava Eu também vote mesmo
eu vim com a classe trabalhadora aí ela
saca esse besouro dentro desse negócio
de hambúrguer tentando já sair fora do
prédio para vazar e o menino veio atrás
sobrando Ei e o pics nada ainda e ela
andando querendo fugir menino solta os
alarmes me tocando fumentando
bota estralando ela se agonia entregue o
hambúrguer para ele fala sai daqui vai
te embora sai ele vai para casa né
tentando entender com esse hambúrguer
não indignado você ficar do hambúrguer
em casa o povo [__] mano um
hambúrguer pelo menos uma maionese
temperada e tal ele abre a caixa rola
bosta prega nele aí começa aquela coisa
de virar herói ser herói é top agora
virar o herói vocês podem prestar
atenção que o herói passa uns três dias
se [__] isso é um bom sinal né quando
pior o processo mais Hype ficou dele
sério cara uma roupa de herói uma
armadura assim muito irado eu acho que é
porque passou pela próstata você sentiu
aquele lá já passou para o DNA tem uma
voz igual da do robô do Tony Stark que
fica falando com ele por dentro assim
olá Jaime ao sistema vai calibrar né
Igual o iPhone quando a gente tem que
calibrar ele assim para sabe pegar as
coordenadas e tal leva ele pra
estratosfera é linda lá de cima Redonda
ih terraplanista como foi que eles
gravaram isso mas tudo que vai volta
desfeito numa velocidade asa preparada
armadura que eu tô falando passou da
próstata aí disse querem ir para casa
armadura agora voando quebrando coluna
prédio tudo herói não é herói é sempre
assim sabe uma galera mas quebra uns
carros e umas coisas ele também parte um
ônibus no meio né que isso aí também é
normal coisa que todo mundo faz aí ele
volta e chega em casa e fica nu eu vou
que 1.500 antes de Cristo Ele crescia
ficava de short aí esse aqui ficou a
tecnologia está no cu aí ele ficou uma
luz assim tipo Doutor destaque só que
nas costas a família discutindo aquela
loucura né mas na verdade
[Música]
ele vai encontrar a Jenny para saber o
que de diabo foi isso quando ele
encontra ela ela já tá fugindo já tem é
bala atrás dele o que é que ele faz Bota
ela junto e vai para casa dele confusão
grande ali discussão
e ela fala que é esse cara velho é a
família diz que é o Besouro e eu digo
que é um bosta e ela conta que é uma
arma militar e que o mundo corre perigo
quando tem uma arma militar é assim cara
eles bolam um plano né o tio dele é
daqueles que ajeita qualquer coisa sabe
então tem quando dá problema na
televisão chama essa pessoa ela num
instante conserta o vilão já estão lá
para legenda também a mulher diz pro
carro né vá buscar o rola bosta aí o tio
deles mostra um bloqueador de sinal que
bota tipo todas as câmeras de segurança
assistindo chapolinzão vamos lá eu boto
isso lá ou 60 faz o que tem que fazer e
depois plantar eles vão na empresa e
entra lá para pegar um relógio eu não
entendi muito bem também está em
espanhol galera perdoa aí chega o cabo
do Mal aquela pessoa que você olha já
pensa assim meu irmão independente
independente você tá errado primeira
luta acontece
ele vira o rola bosta quer que o cabo do
mal faz ele se transforma também como
escaravelho do mal e já é um super
saudável o traje faz tudo para ele ajuda
muito acaba não sabe lutar mas o traje é
inteligente então ele já vai lutando
combatendo entendeu tiro de foguete Gaia
de pau caco de telha e armadura já tá
quase vencendo o cabo do mal só que
também já tá para matar e o menino ele é
do bem ele é tão bonzinho ele é tão
galera e o cabo do Mal começa a bater
nele chega o tio bate no cara com o
carro pega o Jaime
ela leva os cabra pra eles casa dela que
é uma mansão do pai dela ir para um
relógio ela faz é a briga agora que eu
entendi abriu a sala lá e entra lá que
lá a gente descobre que o pai dela era o
rola bosta Azul ele é rico ele é um
herói e ele tem uma caverna ele é o
Batman só que ele é azul tinder ele
começa a mexer nas coisas e ela dá uma
roupa nova para ele né coisa do pai dela
ela conta a história dela como foi a
vida dela ela é aquela coisa do da
personagem também para você se aproximar
do personagem você fala assim [__]
porque a galera fez isso com ela velho
Poxa as pessoas são más aí eu te disse
que descobriu umas coisas não vou dizer
as coisas né se você quiser saber Você
assiste lá o filme mas são as coisas que
eles entendem mais tudo que tá
acontecendo papa o filme fica mais
explicado e tal aí quase enrola o
primeiro beijo chega o tchê para
anunciar que tinha descoberto as porras
que eu disse que não ia dizer que Mas
uma coisa de descobrir que é importante
a gente descobrir que só tira o Besouro
dele morto porque já tá ligado ao
cérebro dele ele fica puto porque aí vem
os helicópteros fudeu tô indo pra casa
dele a casa dele a família mesmo [__]
merda [__] madre a galera andando já
perto da casa a gente com arma bope O
Roni Swatch o gato ele já vira o bicho
Besouro e sai voando pra casa dele e o
povo já invade a casa dele quebra tudo
bota a família tudo doendo e encontra no
quarto o bichinho os vizinhos tudo
olhando dizendo eu sabia que ele mexia
com droga clonagem de cartão uau
a bala no cabo e ele protegendo a
família aí uma arma super sônica né sem
sem matar que ele é do bem a vilã dentro
do helicóptero
tudo eles começam a testar Azar para ver
o que é que o escaravelho É capaz eles
conseguem capturar ele né Tava tentando
defender a família também que se destrói
lá e aí chega Jenny né que é a minha
amiga Bruna Marquezine acontece as
coisas que eu não vou falar aqui também
porque eu não vou contar o filme aqui
para vocês se você quiser você ver e a
família quer ajudar depois que levar o
cabo e a Jenny leva eles para uma nave
Hype Ela é Rica Pai o tio pilota porque
o cabra mancha das tecnologias tablet
essas coisas sabe jogar a imagem do
tablet para televisão ó lá até a velha
avó dele vai também rapaz como é que
pode né a pessoa depois de velha andar
de nave ó me perguntaram qual era meu
sonho obrigado eu pelo pão de cada dia
eu gosto da sua concretarismo eu acho
que os idosos eles podem fazer as coisas
eles começaram a pegar a arma a velha
pega uma metralhadora Que legal né Muito
bonita a imagem de uma metralhadora na
mão de uma velha eu acho que todo velho
quando aposentar tinha que ganhar uma
metralhadora eles vão para onde tem as
pesquisas lá né para salvar o Jaime
cheio de guarda já esperando para
começar o quebra pau a nave do pai dela
é tipo de cascudo também começa a andar
por cima dos negócios é muito é irado
velho Por isso os caras que eu gosto de
olhar para a tela se eu ficar lá na
legenda olha fumo a nave inseto solta
uma Catinga é uma maria fedida não era
um cascudo tá ligado que que legal os
inset 700 representado e ele já estão
começando a extração dos cara velho do
menino já tá quase matando ele a energia
que está sendo drenado desses cara velha
já tá indo já monte de roupa que é como
se fosse um exército entendeu Por isso
que ele é tão importante a Jenny a irmã
dele tá na função lá deitando procurando
as coisas já e ele começa a delirar já
viajando de dor o Besouro está no DNA
cara ele começa a ter uma viagem tipo
quando você já tomou
não deixar a mulher que aquele Morro do
processo o outro cabo do mal de outra
armadura já tá recebendo da energia dele
também James pode o sistema de energia
do lugar mas ele tá tão conectado com
besouro que ele se transforma o cara
[__] sai correndo atrás da família e o
cabo do mal que já pegou da energia dele
foi atrás dele meu amigo aí o [__] é
grelha para dar em 10 rola bosta levou
sozinho sente Gaia de pau quebrando de
ter alvenaria paralelepípedo o cabo do
Mal até igual um Transformers já ficou
maior com besouro Ele parece estar sem
energia ele não quer ligar não funciona
não herói ele tá tipo um cosplay tá com
a roupa e tal tem até impotência assim
mas não sai nada parece um soldado a vó
dele derruba vem outro ela derruba
também e a Jenny agora que vai se
levantar agora desmaiou da Explosão do
sistema de energia ele Já correu com a
nave e ele volta para procurar o pessoal
quer pegar a Jenny quer pegar também a
irmã dele que também tá lá aí meu amigo
o Besouro liga meu patrão foi sal por
soldado viu
e traumatismo e traumatismo sua irmã não
é todo mundo se reúne a família aquela
coisa bonita que é legal né em casa
briga por causa de uma pia que deixa
pingando aberto um pouco mas ali eles
estavam nesse sentido infeliz Unidos aí
o cabra do Mal consegue pegar ele briga
de cachorro grande meu amigo tesouro
toda azul ou todo vermelho né assim
parecendo aquele meme do PT e o PT hein
briga de facão Cruel ww
e o Besouro apanhando mas ele consegue
ganhar porque ele ama a família dele o
amor vence todas as fronteiras a Jenny
tá lá no no helicóptero né com a vilã
com a Hillary parece a Hillary Clinton
mulher ela dá um jeito de escapar que eu
não vou falar quem quiser assiste eu não
vou contar o filme todo o Jaime pega o
cabo do mal também não vou falar o que
acontece também quem quiser assiste ele
pega e vai pra nada e eles vão embora
não é assim tão simples né mas é porque
também não enfim é muito efeito especial
não posso fazer toda explosão que tem no
filme aqui como é que eu vou fazer mas
enfim todo mundo feliz todo mundo
emocionado ele se olha né aquela coisa
parece que vai rolar o primeiro beijo e
eles nada de se beijar ele é aqueles
cabra que faz raiva que você tá
assistindo sabe que ele é lindo mas ele
é lerdo você fica pensando é gringo não
tem como brasileiro não dá isso aí
entende João Guilherme de cropped não
vacina desse jeito Eles voltam para casa
né tudo queimado Detonado Graças a Deus
não tinha cachorro qualquer coisa de
filme que despenca ou pega fogo eu fico
pensando meu Deus será que tem cachorro
eles fazem churrasco eles pensam assim
ah tá tudo arrebentado mesmo cervejinha
com de verdade ela dá uma casa para ele
não é nada mais justo Depois de toda
essa confusão ele acompanha ela até a
moto né ele fica flertando ali e tal
você quer uma bezerra Azul assim você
quebrando Marquezine né e tal e aquele
cara assim não tá só curtindo Ah só nada
tá só de boa que aí ele se beijam ai pai
para ele leva ela Voando para casa né
ela eu mesmo jamais iria o cão que vai
embora pra casa E aí acabou vocês pedem
muito mas vocês não clica em gostei para
dizer assim eu estive aqui eu gostei ai
como é que eu vou fazer outro eu sei que
vocês passam por aqui vocês não dá
sinalização se você quiser comentar aqui
embaixo também Qual o próximo filme para
eu fazer eu posso me esforçar para fazer
para vocês se você clicar em gostei aí
Bruna muita sorte para você aí em
Hollywood precisar de alguém algum filme
para dizer assim siga aquele carro eu
posso ser o taxista não preciso nem
falar esse vídeo não é uma publi tá eu
tô fazendo porque eu quero mesmo fazendo
do fundo do meu coração e não tem nada a
ver também com eu estar pedindo para
Bruna Marquezine me botar em um papel no
filme de Hollywood
eu tô brincando gente logo mais no meu
Instagram eu digo o dia da minha próxima
luta hein eu quero que vocês me assistam
hein galera da Inglaterra você me dá uma
chance velho eu vim treinar
valeu valeu beijinho
[Música]